well inflation will impact holiday
spending this year but it doesn't mean
Las Vegas isn't making money city has
become a very popular destination to
spend the holidays and because of the
pandemic people are valuing experiences
over Goods
the weather is moderate but there's a
nice little chill in the air we have
world-class dining and great places to
stay and it's a great place if you're
going to have a family reunion to all
get together and nobody has to do the
dishes when you're done with
Thanksgiving
um but I think what we've seen so much
with inflation and gas prices is we
would expect to have already seen some
major impacts on travel and Las Vegas
revenue and we just haven't seen that
buying tickets to a sporting event or a
concert has become very popular since
it's an experience that you can share
with someone else but retailers still
trying to get you in that store so
they're rolling out more deals than ever
if your inbox hasn't already exploded
this morning then you haven't signed up
for enough store email account